vous succédez à Jean-Christophe Lagarde
à la présidence de l'UDI Ludi compte 6
députés une trentaine de sénateurs
quelle est la ligne politique est-ce que
vous êtes dans une alliance avec le
gouvernement ou dans l'opposition nous
sommes dans l'opposition mais nous
sommes indépendants je veux dire
aujourd'hui
nous sommes responsables parce que comme
d'autres nouveaux tons les textes quand
ils nous paraissent de voir et de voter
parce qu'il y a des attentes pour le
pays des attentes pour la population qui
est en difficulté on voit bien les
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat les
problèmes énergétiques dont nous venons
de parler
les problèmes sociaux parce que il y a
beaucoup dans dans les budgets d'absence
par exemple sur le logement sur la
dépendance
beaucoup d'angles morts donc nous nous
citons dans une position responsable
mais en même temps indépendante
c'est-à-dire que il y a pas de
systématisme et vous parliez des votes
au Sénat il y a une majorité sénatoriale
mais il y a aussi une indépendance de
notre part et nous assumons cette
indépendance est-ce que justement
l'alliance avec les LR à de l'avenir et
à quelles conditions
là aussi vous pouvez retourner la
question est-ce que les LR ont envie
d'avoir des partenaires
écoutez je les verrai je les entendrai
surtout une fois que nous connaîtrons la
ligne politique qui aura été définie par
la nouvelle direction des républicains
aujourd'hui des républicains
essaient de définir quel type de droite
va présider au mouvement est-ce que
c'est une droite
niçoise vendéenne
voilà moi je sais pas si c'est une
droite qui se referme sur elle-même qui
regarde sur sa droite ou qui a des
partenaires et comment ça se passe en
2023 à l'Assemblée nationale pour
trouver des majorités j'attends de
connaître un certain nombre de réponses
et d'orientation pour pouvoir y répondre
et pouvoir nous positionner
[Musique]